So when you say what is what is the game
what is reality reality with a capital r
is that love and beauty and life
they exist everywhere but we must be the
vibrational condition
for it to reveal itself through us or if
not we get caught up in small our
reality which is simply the experience
of our beliefs
we experience our beliefs whether they
be true or not
um you know I used to do a a a practical
joke years ago when I was in college and
uh we would go up to one of the our
fellow students and we light the match
blow it out and then quickly touch the
person with a cold match
their thinking we're touching it with a
hot match and suddenly they form a
blister a heat blister on their hand
and they get upset a little bit we said
no we touched you with a cold match
follow me then we go to the next person
light a match blow it out touching with
the cold match they get a blister more
often than not
so they were having an experience of
their relief they weren't having an
experience of that which which reality
cold match
they were experiencing their belief
so humanity is experiencing a belief in
separation
not enoughness lack limitation they're
experiencing that they're experiencing a
reality that's not real
it's why we call it the world of
appearances
because things that appear to be real
are simply thought forms that we're
experiencing what is the role of the
illusions that we experience the
anything other than love and connection
and
God frequency energy God Consciousness
Christ Consciousness whatever you want
to call it what's the role of it
well it gives us feedback as to what
what we are attached to in our
Consciousness now let me break that down
just take the word problem as an example
like people have a problem now the word
problem comes from the word emblem
so a problem is emblematic of what's in
our awareness okay so if we're attached
to a particular thought form or
perception a belief an interpretation of
a past experience then that becomes
emblematic as an issue in our life so it
gives us feedback we're getting feedback
as to what is in our awareness
so if we keep repeating something over
and over and over again there's a belief
that probably has an emotion attached to
it it probably has a um the vanity of
the ego saying mine as I said in other
words that's my opinion that's my
thought that's my belief
which creates a you know attachment
then all of that shows up as experience
but it's feedback we're getting we're
getting feedback all the time
so that small reality is is is you say
what's this role it's giving us feedback
we're actually having a direct
experience of our belief even if the
belief is unconscious how do we grow
from from from seeing ourselves through
someone else and then what are the ways
that we can turn inside internally and
what are the sort of like modalities or
techniques that we can use to grow and
learn about ourselves by looking inward
so when we when we are what you're
describing projecting
parts of ourselves onto someone else we
have to take responsibility and own that
you know so so total responsibility is
one of the first ways of growing and
then you have to say Okay what is this
that I am projecting projecting is it um
a lack of self-love and appreciation is
it Lack of self spiritual self-esteem
you know what what is it that I'm
placing on to this other being so when I
take responsibility for it now I can
become still and I can allow to float up
the actual belief or thought that's
generating that projection now that
belief or thought is a lie it's not the
truth it's a lie anything that's less
than God less than intelligence and a
beauty and life is it's a lie because
we're Spiritual Beings emerging from the
Eternal so anything unlike that is a lie
that we're telling ourselves how do we
discern then
like how do we know what's a lie versus
like is that is it just if anything is
not positive or is it I think it's not
life-affirming is a lie
when we hear that thought it's not
life-affirming that it's not it's not
the truth it might be an experience
we're having
but it's not the truth of our being
a lie believed acts as a law until
neutralized any lie that we have that's
running us it will become our personal
law we can we can change States we can
change relationships we can change jobs
but that lie will run us and it will act
as our personal law until we neutralize
it look within we see the LIE we
dismantle it
through prayer through meditation
through forgiveness
until it's no longer operating within us
now we become free and we see life
differently we see people differently
there's less judgmentalism
you know uh with this less projection
but it you know it doesn't it it takes a
degree of um
radical sincerity and inner work real
sincere wanting to wake up and not just
because once you have a projection you
put it on the world
the ego then says it fights to say I'm
right yeah yeah I'm right about this
and that's one of the ways that we slow
ourselves down because we Embrace I'm
right
and then you look for it right if you
have an idea that you know
um guys always cheat on me then you go
and look for it right or if you have an
idea that the world treats me terribly
you actually go out and I'm only just
I'm like speaking from experience like
you go out into your life and you
actually look for look to justify yes
belief and you'll find it and you're
also helping to create a condition for
that to show up right explain that more
because that's the tricky one yeah so we
live in a field of infinite potential
infinite possibilities but the
possibilities can only come in a
manifestation if the condition is right
you know you can have a you can have a
seed the seed has the potential to be
whatever olive tree apple tree but it's
not going to do that unless the
condition is right it has to be planted
it has to have the proper soil Sunshine
water when the condition is right it
shows up so that's true about anything
uh if if if you're holding a c thought
whether it's the sea thought as
affirmative
or whether the seed thought is not
affirmative you're if you create the
condition that thought will emerge so if
you're looking uh for other words the
world's a bad place what you're looking
for you're looking with
you're looking with that Dynamic so
you're also helping to create the
condition for that
we're vibrational beings
so we're vibing at the condition of what
we are afraid of what we cherish what we
love
the bad news is that oftentimes what we
are afraid of
has more emotional impact
you know the the the universal law says
you don't get what you want you get what
you're interested in
so if you're looking around for
negativity
then you study of the condition to have
that experience if you're looking around
for that which is affirmative and
life-giving then you're beginning to
Trend in that direction it's all lawful
no none of it's personal
you know if you fall off a building
and you hit the ground and go Splat
break your armor so it's not it's not
personal gravity is not personal you
know to you oh you know I'm gonna get
her so we learn to own our projections
begin to have an awareness that we're
actually surrounded uh Einstein once
said you know the question we have to
ask is the universe friendly you know uh
he he figured that it was the friendly
the universe was friendly he was not
working against us I like to use the
word progressives if the universe is
Progressive it's not working against us
so we have to be in alignment with it
and then wonderful things occur because
we're in alignment not because we're
good people you know and we're better
than anyone a weird alignment my friend
um my dear friend NADA she gave me this
little Mantra to say when things are a
little awry and she goes I just stop and
I ask the universe how can it get any
better
I didn't get any better
I should do talks on it all the time
that's the question you ask how can it
get any better and this get better and
you do that even if things are really
good it's true it's true you're totally
right you're exactly right and uh it's
amazing I mean you most you notice it
the most when there's the most contrast
right but it's like you just can't
believe that the Universe lined up
something so magically that you're like
you can do nothing but believe in the
power of saying those those words and
how could it get better than this I'm
gonna get better than this yes and then
the Universe goes we'll show you
I'm infinite look at this
every potentiality available is right
here well in the Manifest World there um
obviously their Serendipity is a
coincidences that occur that you did not
plan
that just show up opportunities that
that pop up that show up you beat the
right person at the right time you
realize oh something's happening here
and then there's a note then you start
to have an awareness that you have less
and less anxiety and anxiousness and a
greater sense of peace
and a greater sense of peace is not tied
in to an external event it's like
sometimes you know why am I so happy
and why why why why do I have so much
peace because nothing seems to has
changed in the external world
but I'm feeling the greatest sense of
happiness and joy and peace
that means you're coming more in harmony
with your intrinsic nature it has
nothing to do with the external world
and now as I said earlier conditions
will start to shape-shift
in order to give birth so you can give
birth
to your highest desire your soul desire
your heart's desire if you like this
clip and you want to hear the whole
episode click at the bottom of your
screen